[Applause]
[Music]
we're joined by the god of thunder
chris hemsworth
very much it's really fun to get to be a
six foot character when you're a 5'3
girl
you know that doesn't happen often in
your life
his name is
self-explanatory and it's exciting and
humbling and i don't know if they're
trying to usher me out to the finish
line quickly and get on with it but
either way i'll take it it's been a lot
of bloody fun i think everyone was
really having a good time and you can
tell when you watch it like it's a party
valkyrie valkyrie no she's just a big
pile of mush you know i think taka
wanted to make a romantic comedy set in
space and
it's that i've spent years in space snow
at this point so it's becoming really
normal to be
she's into the suits
she loves musical theater well well well
what's happening team we all right let's
give a shout out to all these all these
wonderful cosplayers out here man
i love it tiger ytc hello sir
i didn't ask him to do that okay this
genre is the taika genre i gotta ask you
a little bit more about tekken is he
like a big brother is he like a funny
uncle is he a tyrant what's he like on
set
a bit of all three i guess i love it
there's zero pressure on me
and there's all the pressure on taika
taika is just amazing he's a force of
nature every i'll be in the sprint
and um you know i decided to put some
goats in there and see what he's gonna
do with them i'm really like amazed with
all the actors i managed to get into
this film you know that we had a plan
the whole dance that turkey and i had
planned we didn't get to shoot it again
that'll be for another film but a whole
gore
dance you know sometimes with villains
you just need them to be bad and you
know not amazing dancers uh i'm pretty
sure if i say anything
a marvel sniper will get me i can tell
you
nothing i can tell you thor is in it but
you know how marvel is they won't even
let us know what's going on and so i'm
about to go in this theater and find out
what the hell we did how does it feel to
know that people are talking more about
your biceps than his
well i mean
that was all my doing i wouldn't ask her
that no no no let's just keep that
between us okay hats off to anyone who
has to deal with acrylic nails i
couldn't do anything am i a fully
fledged guardian yes yes i think i am
that nice oh that's okay
no you're all good christian bell you
can bump into me anytime you want to
gore and the mighty thor in thor four
more
there it is the fans can tell me why is
valkyrie important
[Music]
she's a badass
yeah
i hope everybody loves the movie thanks
for having me this is the best i'm so
happy to be back i feel so lucky to be
back with this croom
made this movie for you you're the the
best fan base in the world
we love you we love you thank you it's
just been
unlike anything else i've done
[Music]